from Modern masterpieces to cult
classics these frightful films never got
a sequel or remake
the central theme of the 2010 South
Korean horror movie I saw the devil is
the price of obsessive Revenge after
government operative Kim So Young played
by libyanghun luces his pregnant fiancee
to Choi Min 6 Yang Kung Chul he swears
Vengeance and vows to pick apart the
mass murderer's entire life even as Jang
adds more victims Kim deliberately lets
him walk free so he can continue to
stalk and torment him the Los Angeles
Times praised I saw the devil for
balancing its bloody Mayhem with a
realistic emotional undercurrent its
tragedy sets the movie apart from
typical horror films in paste's
retrospective review they claimed the
film's violent meditation on Revenge was
criminally overlooked during its initial
release and declared it the best horror
movie of 2010 according to the rap the
English language remake writes to I saw
the devil were optioned in 2013 with
writer Simon Barrett and Adam Wingard
set to tackle the adaptation however
nothing has come of the project yet in
2021 Barrett told ihorror.com that it's
probably for the best saying even though
it would have been much different than
the original it would have just probably
annoyed some people
long before he helmed the Lord of the
Rings trilogy or King Kong Peter Jackson
crafted low-budget horror comedies in
his native New Zealand among the most
notorious of Jackson's early work is the
1992 zombie movie brain dead released in
North America as Dead Alive the
hilarious cult classic is considered one
of the goriest films ever made
[Music]
plague written rat monkey from Skull
Island at the Wellington Zoo become
feral and Rise as ravenous zombies
Timothy Baum's Lionel tries to keep the
undead outbreak a secret even as the
number of zombies grows after his mother
Vera becomes infected with nearly 80
gallons of fake blood reportedly used
for the climactic sequence brain dead is
Jackson at his most gruesome while
Jackson told uprox that he's working on
a 4K remastering of brain dead that's
about the extent of anything that's
currently happening with the title
following an acclaimed career as the
co-creator and co-star of the sketch
comedy series key and peel Jordan Peele
turned his attention to horror peel made
his future debut with 2017's get out
acting as writer director and producer
for the film the film follows Chris
Washington played by Daniel caluya as he
travels with his girlfriend played by
Allison Williams to meet her family in
Upstate New York shortly after arriving
Chris discovers that the community
Harbors a dark secret and that he's the
next Target for their Insidious goals
you know
sorry man
get out yo yo yo
Peel's story is filled with sharp satire
and biting social commentary about the
black experience in the United States
named one of the best horror films of
all time by Rotten Tomatoes the movie
was a major critical and Commercial
Success the film even won peel and Oscar
for best original screenplay peel told
Business Insider that get out was the
first of five socially conscious horror
movies he planned on making saying I've
been working on these premises about
these different social demons these
innately human monsters that are woven
into the fabric of how we think and how
we interact Peel's second horror feature
us hit theaters in 2019. his third
effort nope came out in 2022 while these
movies have common social commentaries
to date they're all considered
Standalone entries there are currently
no plans to revisit get out
Drew Goddard and Joss Whedon who had
previously collaborated on Buffy the
Vampire Slayer and Angel reunited for
the critically acclaimed 2011 feature
film The Cabin in the Woods Goddard
directed with Whedon producing a
screenplay that they wrote together The
Cabin in the Woods sees a group of
college students vacationing at a remote
cabin only to be unwittingly targeted by
a cabal of scientists the scientists
must complete a supernatural ritual to
stop the apocalypse so they unleash a
number of common horror movie Monsters
to Prey Upon the students The Cabin in
the Woods leans into its self-aware
storytelling poking fun about
established horror tropes while
subverting audience expectations in an
interview with total film Whedon
referred to the movie as a very loving
hate letter although the ending doesn't
leave much to follow up with for a
sequel that's never stopped a horror
franchise before however Goddard told
Fandango every version of continuing the
story undercuts the ending that we had
in cabin and I just feel like that
continues to be the perfect ending for
that movie and I never want to undercut
it
though filmmaker Paul W S Anderson may
be best known for helming most of the
Resident Evil movies his finest horror
movie is arguably 1997's Event Horizon
combining Science Fiction with
supernatural horror Event Horizon sees a
group of astronauts becoming the victims
of a spaceship possessed by demonic
forces in a behind-the-scenes feature on
the Event Horizon DVD producer Jeremy
bolt described the film as a Ghost Story
in space she tore a hole in our universe
the gateway to another dimension though
not financially or critically successful
during its theatrical release Event
Horizon found greater success in the
Home Video Market and has since become a
bona fide cult classic in an interview
with inverse about the movie Anderson
remembered a piece of advice actor Kurt
Russell gave him in the wake of the
movie's disappointing initial run
Russell said in 20 years that's going to
be the movie you're really glad you made
it seems the actor was right while
variety reported in 2019 that a
television series adaptation was in the
works there hasn't been any further
information released about a possible
follow-up
from Doctor's sleep to midnight mass
Mike Flanagan has become one of the most
celebrated horror filmmakers to emerge
in recent years one of Flanagan's
earliest features which he directed
edited and co-wrote was the 2013
supernatural horror movie Oculus Haley
and Tim played by Karen Gillen and
Brenton Thwaites respectively are
siblings investigating the cursed Legacy
of a haunted mirror that destroyed their
family when they were children the story
unfolds across two time periods moving
between their childhood trauma and their
present day investigation many of
Flanagan's narrative themes seen in his
acclaimed Netflix original series The
Haunting of Hill House are prominently
on display in Oculus most notably the
end of childhood innocence in 2014
Flanagan talked to Joe Blow about the
possibility of a sequel while he noted
that he'd be interested in doing one if
he found an exciting story he had no
real interest saying the last thing I'd
want to do is get in the business of
franchising the movie and crank out
sequels to an idea even if it's worn out
grief and the loss of family run heavy
through the Australian horror movie the
babadook written and directed by
Jennifer Kent in her featured
directorial debut in the wake of losing
her husband Essie Davis's Amelia
struggles to raise her young son Samuel
played by Noah Wiseman This is
complicated further when the two are
menaced by a supernatural creature known
as the babadook Kent strove to utilize
practical effects throughout the entire
production as Emilia and Samuel are both
poisoned by their grief Kent's special
effects choices augment the film's theme
of how people create monsters from their
personal Darkness he
how many times I wished it was you not
him that died the babadook is truly one
of a kind and Kent knows this better
than anyone in an interview with IGN she
claims that she owns the film's sequel
rights to ensure that one will never be
made she elaborated it's just not what
the film is about it would destroy the
Integrity of everything we worked so
hard to protect
Sex and Death walk hand in hand in the
2014 indie horror flick it follows
written and directed by David Robert
Mitchell the movie involves a sexually
transmitted Supernatural entity and the
variety of forums it utilizes to close
in on its prey Jay height played by
Micah Monroe is the latest person to
receive this curse and searches for a
way to escape her Grim fate it follows
received considerable critical Acclaim
upon its theatrical release in 2015 with
the Rotten Tomatoes critical consensus
describing it as smart original and
above all terrifying it follows is the
rare modern horror film that works on
multiple levels and leaves a lingering
Sting with its steady escalation of
suspense interwoven with its narrative
themes it follows became a solid success
with Monroe specifically lauded for her
performance according to Entertainment
Weekly though there was some talk of a
follow-up to it follows in 20 15 there
has been little information about any
project development since then Mitchell
told Digital Spy that he does have some
ideas of where the story could go but
for now he wants to keep it as a
standalone a24 is an independent
entertainment company that has achieved
a lot of acclaims since its launch in
2012. for over a decade the studio has
been releasing many horror film
favorites like under the skin the Witch
and 2018's hereditary hereditary marked
the featured directorial debut of
ariaster throughout the filmmaster who
also wrote the screenplay explores the
dissolution of a family in the face of
immense grief hereditary begins with a
grounded relatable tragedy before
steadily progressing into outright
Supernatural Terror after the Graham
Family loses their young daughter in a
horrific accident they become targets of
a Sinister group involved with demons
and malevolent spirits
this was painted above the body right in
blood the film is a searing look at a
divided family manipulated by forces
beyond their comprehension it's hard to
imagine a follow-up when hereditary's
stunning finale ends quite conclusively
so perhaps it's for the best that the
story remains untouched
channeling the Aesthetics and styles of
1980s horror The House of the devil is
one of the earliest feature films
written and directed by acclaimed
filmmaker Ty West according to the
independent West's quest for
authenticity came right down to the
director shooting the movie on 16
millimeter film and releasing
promotional copies on VHS college
student Samantha Hughes played by
Jocelyn Donahue answers a call for a
babysitting gig at a remote Mansion only
to learn that the job is not exactly
what was advertised Samantha soon finds
herself in the middle of an occult
ritual after discovering the true
occupants of the house were gruesomely
murdered by her employers more than just
wearing his influences on his sleeve
West subverts expectations about the
genre to keep the audience on its toes
while building the tension and violence
in equal measure a love letter to 80s
horror right down to its commentary on
the satanic Panic The House of the devil
features West's Phil making strengths on
full display the New York Times sang its
Praises for the film saying that West's
use of setting and suspense holds up
against works by legendary filmmakers
years his senior as West has become more
widely known for his recent movie
trilogy of X its prequel Pearl and the
upcoming Maxine he seems to have left
the house of the devil to stand on its
own for now
Canadian filmmaker David Cronenberg is
widely recognized as the master of body
horror with his 1983 film video drone
being one of the standouts of his career
along with cronenberg's signature Gore
and grotesque body Transformations video
drone tackles mass media consumption
specific specifically how the rising UHF
television stations of the time
addressed sex and violence the film
focuses on cable station CEO Max rent
played by James Woods as he begins
airing video drone a program from
Malaysia that allegedly consists of
actual snuff films after Nikki brand
played by Debbie Harry becomes obsessed
with the program and vanishes Max learns
that videodrome actually airs from
Pittsburgh he decides to investigate
further and discovers a surreal and
Strange World he never imagined
television is reality
and reality is less than television
video drone is a surreal exploration of
the Infectious impact that media
consumption has on the subconscious
standing out among cronenberg's most
acclaimed films paste even called it his
best movie writing video drone is horror
down to its bones A Shard of Francis
mccorrical Mania wielded by the genre's
most cerebral Master back in 2012
deadline announced that Adam Berg would
direct a remake of video drone
modernizing the story as a big budget
sci-fi action thriller as of January
2023 no further information on this
remake has been released and
cronenberg's classic has remained
untouched
if the 1973 classic British film The
Wicker man originally popularized the
idea of folk horror movies 2019's
mid-somar updated the sub-genre with
modern sensibilities and a bigger body
count written and directed by Ari Astor
the movie takes place in the middle of a
summertime celebration in Scenic Sweden
with its sun-soaked setting and cheerful
residence midsomar is a thoroughly
memorable take on the genre in the
traumatizing aftermath of losing her
entire family Florence Pugh's Dany
travels with her boyfriend and their
friends to a mid-summer festival in
Sweden the group discovers a strange
commune behind the celebration with
bizarre customs and rituals designed to
Rob individuals of their sanity and
eventually their lives Astor told
Fandango that since they share some
themes midsomar can be seen as quote
something of a companion to hereditary
however both of these two are ultimately
Standalone and to date no follow-up to
midsom has been announced
Robert Egger's feature film debut 2015's
the witch captured the Grim side of
early America effectively blending folk
and supernatural horror growing up in
New Hampshire Eggers was fascinated by
the local folklore fostered by the
Region's history of witch trials
discussing his goals for the film with
the Atlantic Edgars said I wanted to
make an archetypal New England Horror
Story something that would feel like an
inherited nightmare a Puritan nightmare
from the past Eggers put his childhood
fears into a story about isolation and
being shunned from society causing his
protagonists to fall prey to the horrors
existing On The Fringe set in New
England during the 1630s the witch
follows a small English family when
they're banished from their puritanical
Colony for a religious falling out as
they attempt to run their own Homestead
their crops fail in the face of the
impending winter and they're targeted by
a local witch working to tear the entire
family apart you bring the crop sealed
you cannot
do nothing same car would using only
natural and period appropriate light the
witch is arguably Eggers at his most
atmospheric and unsettling while Outlets
like rotten tomatoes named it the best
horror film of 2016 Eggers told
Entertainment Weekly that he has no
plans for a sequel he stated if I wanted
to know what happens after the last shot
of the film I would have made a longer
movie
one of the most influential Visionaries
in horror films is Italian filmmaker
Dario Argento his early work in the
giallo sub-genre has inspired countless
storytellers across a variety of mediums
and earned him great praise from critics
garage even called him quote the most
influential horror director outside of
Hitchcock argento's 1985 film phenomena
follows Jennifer played by Jennifer
Connolly who travels to a remote
all-girls boarding school in Switzerland
while there she uses her powers to
communicate with insects to stop a
serial killer preying on women around
the school phenomena combined
supernatural horror with the classic
Diallo trappings of mystery plots with
slasher and psychological Thriller
elements with argento's usual Flair for
hyper-stylized visuals and a set of
insects and arachnids to match the
film's creepy themes phenomena stance
among argento's most beloved works
though the original International cut of
the film was a heavily edited version
titled creep Argento fans can see all
versions of the film rendered in 4K
Ultra HD in the upcoming 2023 home
release by synapse films while this cult
classic went nearly 40 years without a
sequel that may change soon in 2022 the
Italian Studio titanus announced that it
had plans to make a sequel to phenomena
set in the modern day with a mix of U.S
and international talents the film was
in development as of October 2022
Adam wingard's 2014 horror film The
Guest centers around the Peterson Family
mourning the loss of their son Caleb in
the war in Afghanistan they're
unexpectedly visited by a former U.S
soldier David Collins played by Dan
Stevens who claims to have been Caleb's
best friend overseas as the Petersons
welcomed David into their home
increasingly violent acts begin to occur
around the family David is at the center
of this lethal escalation which leads
them to wonder about his identity if you
brought money for all of them I'll cut
you a deal you can take them all off my
hands no I'm going to kill you driven by
a Darkly Charming performance from
Stevens the guest doesn't necessarily
surprise its audience with twists but it
still manages to be a captivating Thrill
Ride beloved by critics upon its release
it has become a cult hit over time in
2021 screenwriter Simon Barrett told
comicbook.com that a potential follow-up
would go in a radically different
direction because he never intended to
make a sequel for the film Wingard
confirmed in 2022 just how different
that direction would be when he released
the guest 2 as a Musical soundtrack in a
press release Wingard explained embedded
within the song titles the album artwork
and the music itself are hidden clues
that lead the listener down the path a
sequel would take in an interview with
Empire Wingard noted that working on the
soundtrack inspired him and Barrett and
they're now considering an actual film
or TV sequel to the guest however
there's no word yet on if they'll go
ahead with it
one of the most chilling movies to come
out of South Korea is nah Hong jins the
whaling channeling a mix of horror movie
influences the 2016 film Blends
everything from body horror and demonic
possession to ghost stories and
socio-political commentary after a
mysterious Japanese man played by Jun
kurumura visits a small South Korean
town its inhabitants suddenly become
enraged and kill their own families as
two police officers investigate what
happened suspecting the Japanese man is
the culprit they soon find that there
are paranormal forces at work the
whaling received near Universal critical
Acclaim upon its release due largely to
its haunting atmosphere and an
unforgettably Bleak ending in 2017
screen Daley reported that Ridley Scott
was interested in producing an English
language remake however producer hosung
Kim noted that the setting and
Sensibility of the whaling would be
difficult to translate into a western
remake though hosung and na weren't
completely opposed to the idea there's
been no word of the reboots since then
starting with the thing in 1982
celebrated filmmaker John Carpenter
launched his apocalypse Trilogy a set of
Standalone movies that conclude with
certain Doom for the human race the
second installment of this informal
Trilogy is 1987's Prince of Darkness the
film is directed by Carpenter from a
screenplay he wrote Under a pseudonym
and it focuses on the arrival of Satan
on earth
a Quantum physicist and his team are
invited to inspect a strange liquid that
they're informed is Satan the liquid
begins to infect and possess the
researchers with the scientists deducing
from their recurring dreams that they
are facing an anti-matter-fueled
apocalypse according to film cred the
concepts behind Prince of Darkness came
from Carpenter's interest in the utterly
uncanny world of quantum physics Prince
of Darkness sees Carpenter at his most
surreal with audiences and critics
marking it among his most underrated
Works Carpenter told consequence of
sound in 2018 that he was considering
turning Prince of Darkness into a TV
series with shutter he further explained
to fandom in 2022 that he's open to
making a sequel to the movie because of
the many fun directions they could go
with its subject matter however no
official plans have been made for a
sequel or series
Spanish filmmaker Jay biona leaned
heavily into classic horror influences
for their 2007 film The Orphanage Bell
and raida's Laura returns to the
orphanage where she grew up with the
intention of reopening it as a
children's clinic her plans get thwarted
when her adopted son played by Roger
princep goes missing as Laura searches
for her son she discovers the orphanage
Harbors a dark secret and a haunted
Legacy of its own screenwriter Sergio G
Sanchez told the deadbolt that his main
influences in crafting the story were
literary Works JM buries Peter Pan
inspired him to Imagine The Story of a
runaway child like Wendy Darling from a
parent's perspective while Henry James
is the turn of the screw gave him the
framework for child-centered Ghost Story
full of adult themes the orphanage was a
critical and box office hit in 2007
becoming the highest grossing movie in
Spain not surprisingly an American
remake was almost immediately announced
in that same year however there has been
little news surrounding the proposed
project since since 2011 when it was
reported on by Bloody Disgusting
the final horror movie that Dario
Argento directed in the 80s 1987's Opera
stands among his best released on
American Home Video as Terror at the
Opera the film is centered on a young
opera singer played by Christina marciak
finally getting her big break to
headline an Italian opera her dreams are
crushed when a horrific Killing Spree
breaks out in the opera house with the
murders resembling the traumatizing
death of her mother years prior she then
sets out to discover the masked Killer's
identity after numerous projects
exploring the supernatural Argento
returned to his more grounded giallo
roots for Opera a gruesome murder
mystery Opera is one of argento's most
critically acclaimed films with slant
calling it his last full-fledged
Masterpiece slick and stylish Opera
demonstrates how far Argento has grown
as a filmmaker setting a high water mark
for the shallow sub-genre that has
seemingly yet to be surpassed this may
also be part of the reason why no one
has tried to remake or revisit it